what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today i will be
talking about an absolutely massive
development in the black clover story a
twist that might change the course of
the entire spade kingdom war arc not
only did we just learn more about the
secret history of the silva family but
the devil queen megikula herself may
have just been defeated i mean this is
black clover so you never know for sure
but this was definitely crazy so let's
get into it if you enjoyed the black
clover content on this channel and you
want us to keep it going you know what
to do just drop a quick like and comment
it only takes a second but it helps a
lot with the youtube algorithm and if
you're new to the channel or maybe you
watch us but you haven't taken the time
to subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain black lover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned we start things off with a
flashback to aussie's fight against
megicula but this time from nozelle's
perspective after the battle ended the
curse that makikula placed on aussie a
slowly took effect and asea grew weaker
and weaker over the course of a year
noel was too young to remember any of
this but noesel remembers all of it and
he remembers how completely helpless and
useless he felt while his mother slowly
succumbed to the curse in fact
megicula's curse not only affected
aussieair but it also had a residual
effect on nozelle if he ever spoke of
megicula's involvement with aussie's
death he would also die and the same
curse would then spread to anyone who
learns about it like some sort of viral
disease that is why dorothy initially
told noel about megicula inside her
glamour world because information shared
inside that dreamlike world does not
trigger the curse as a result of the
curse the rest of the silva family and
basically everyone else went on
believing that aussie's illness was the
result of complications due to her
recently giving birth to noel the fact
that noel was born around the time that
asea was cursed was just a coincidence
and this means that noel spent her
entire life feeling guilty about her
birth bringing about the death of her
mom and yet her birth had nothing to do
with it that in itself is incredibly
tragic when you think about it but
that's just one aspect of this awful
story noesel felt terrible and
absolutely miserable because not only
was he unable to break the curse but he
couldn't even share the truth about what
was really happening with anyone ossier
could tell what he was going through so
she told him that he had done enough and
that he can't keep putting his life in
danger in an attempt to break the curse
ossier told nozelle that he and his
siblings will one day be stronger than
her so they must go on living after a
year in which noezelle could do nothing
but helplessly watch aussie silva died
from the curse
at his mother's funeral noesel vowed to
become strong so that one day he could
avenge his mother and protect his
siblings from ever falling prey to
megicula and it actually turns out that
noesel was extremely worried about his
siblings and their well-being far more
than he let on while pretending to be
this cold and ruthless person on the
outside he was actually quite caring on
the inside but he never let that side of
him show nosel felt that nebra and solid
were getting stronger but they were
still no match for an opponent like
mekikula they did seem to have potential
though so perhaps eventually they could
be strong enough to protect themselves
however noel was unable to control her
own magic as we all remember from way
back at the beginning of the series this
made nozelle think that she was unlikely
to ever get strong enough to fight back
against an opponent like megicula in
order to protect noel and make sure that
she would never find herself in the kind
of situation that their mother found
herself in nozelle told noel that she
was a failure and that she doesn't
belong on the battlefield the thinking
behind this was that if noel lacked
confidence in her magic and in her
fighting abilities she would never take
the kinds of risks that would put her in
danger in the future this is actually
similar to another dramatic family
backstory from a little series called my
hero academia but i won't get into that
because i assume that some of you are
not caught up to that manga but those of
you who are caught up might know what
i'm talking about nozell also told noel
that she killed their mother by being
born although in reality he felt that he
was the one to blame for asia's death
because he failed to do anything to
protect her nozelle felt like a failure
who couldn't protect anyone and so he
pushed noel away because he believed
that he didn't deserve to be in her life
at least not until he became much much
stronger strong enough to protect her
and the rest of his siblings and i mean
i get nozelle's internal conflict and
everything but telling noel that she
killed their mother when he knew that
she didn't was a dick move to put it
lightly even under the circumstances
that was a step too far in my opinion
and definitely not a very dijobo thing
to do to your own sister but noesel was
pretty messed up mentally at this point
so i guess we can't expect him to be
completely rational at any rate noesel
basically dedicated his life to becoming
as strong as possible and eventually he
vowed to become the new wizard king he
has been preparing for his vengeance for
16 years he's been preparing for the
moment when he will face megicula once
again noesel knows that the only way to
avenge his mother and to protect his
siblings from future threats is to kill
megikula himself far from being nervous
or scared when he comes face to face
with this highest ranking devil nosel is
absolutely psyched for this showdown he
puts all of his strength into one
massive mercury magic attack and he rips
mkikula's body apart using sharp blades
made of mercury as aussie had once told
her son his magic is as tough as steel
and as gentle as water and nosel is able
to use these unique properties of
mercury to attack megicula mercilessly
without allowing her to dodge the
attacks makikula's attempts to defend
herself with blood and steel magic are
completely useless which leaves her in
disbelief but even this merciless attack
by noesel is not enough to defeat
megicula on its own nozelle knows that
he will need help in order to deal the
final blow and that help arrives from
none other than his own sister noel
seeing noelle in action noesel knows
that he was wrong about her instead of
trying to convince her to hide from
danger he should have been working with
her so that the two of them could get
stronger together after an absolutely
fierce onslaught together nozella noel
are able to hack a shocked megicula to
pieces seemingly destroying her entire
body including her evil heart as
megicula's body disintegrates aussie's
essence escapes from the rest of the
crumbling body and she is able to share
one final embrace with her beloved
children as nosel and noel look on with
surprise and with tears in their eyes
ossier tells them how truly strong they
have become and it is clear that she is
extremely proud of her children and that
is how this emotional and shocking
chapter ends megikula has seemingly been
defeated by the combined power of
nozelle and noel and some part of
aussie's essence seems to have survived
the death of her body at least in some
form that is crazy stuff but this is
black clover we're talking about and
tabitha has tricked us multiple times
before so we have to be careful the big
question is is megikula really dead has
she really been defeated without the use
of arcane magic or anti-magic now
noesel's mercury magic is really unique
and it could potentially be classified
as arcane magic but that hasn't been
confirmed so it is technically possible
that he managed to defeat a highest
ranked devil without any arcane magic
we'll have to wait and see but if that
turns out to be true it would set a
major precedent for defeating the rest
of the devils this would mean that you
don't necessarily need arcane magic or
anti-magic to defeat a highest ranking
devil however since this is black clover
and since magikala has seemingly died
multiple times before and then just came
back like it was nothing we can't jump
to conclusions megikula could
potentially have another trick up her
sleeve which will allow her to
regenerate yet again or she could just
return to the underworld and wait her
turn to come out once more through the
cliff off itself we can't forget that
megicula never fully manifested into
this world so the rest of her body is
still intact back in the underworld
don't get me wrong it is definitely
possible that mkikula has been defeated
we have seen high-ranked devils killed
before including zagred lilith and namah
but it is also possible that megicula
will return once again and we still
haven't seen her at full power so
because of that i'm leaning towards the
idea that she will probably return at
some point in the future it was also
pretty crazy to see asia's essence
actually manifest and embrace nozelle
and noel was this just a brief symbolic
farewell or is this an indication that
even ossier could return in some form my
guess is that she is probably gone for
good it would be very hard to explain
reviving someone after all that time but
i do love aussie as a character so if
she did come back i wouldn't even be mad
i mean suddenly bringing long dead
characters back to life usually doesn't
work very well in a story but for a
badass milf like ossier i'll allow it
let me know what you guys thought about
this emotional chapter is megikula
really gone for good or will she return
in some form if you do think she'll
return do you think that it will be soon
or later on in the arc once the cliff
fought fully opens also what did you
think about the additional aspects of
the silva family history that we learned
in this chapter while i'm definitely
feeling more sympathetic towards noesel
now that i know everything that he had
to go through i still feel so bad for
noel she had to go through so much abuse
over allegedly killing her mother during
her entire childhood but in reality she
had nothing to do with any of it man
that is really tragic and it just makes
me respect noel and her progression so
much more definitely leave your feedback
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more blacklover content in the future
just leave a quick like it only takes a
second but it helps a lot and if you're
new to the channel or maybe you watch
our videos but you haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting the bell and then
selecting that option that says all if
you don't do that you're still going to
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror i want to give a quick thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma he is
an absolute mad lad and disciple of lord
twigo himself and i can't forget all of
our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including
ingrata pate heffa
water the toasted chi the spike dylan
isadore spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis big buddhist and monkey d quilly
finally thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red-haired raven angel
crews rather indeora very gucci alicia
octor bonnie parks joanne garcia ted no
ted fat boy games corey mcgowan and soul
ray slice and dice if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you